a strong woman with a zest for life and
a passion for teaching michelle's
definitely outgoing um
very funny very family oriented
just a lover of life really
but after planning to undergo what
should have been a simple nose job
whilst living in turkey this is michelle
now since then michelle is now in a
permanent vegetative state and
so she cannot talk and
she cannot sit up she can't do anything
for herself she needs 24-hour care it's
been
very very hard it's been hard for
her daughter it's been hard for my mum
made harder by conflicting reports
first they were told she hadn't been
operated on and had suffered a cardiac
arrest after a general anesthetic but
incisions to michelle's body suggests
otherwise
nobody actually knows what's happened
apart from
michelle and the surgeons
and so
yeah i'd like to
be able to
get closure on the situation
they're suing for more information
berger is a turkish lawyer based in the
uk and says their case is strong there
was nothing
that would
explain
the situation she's in right now unless
something went really wrong
each year millions travel to turkey to
soak up the sun sea and culture
but some book a different type of
package deal
one which includes flights accommodation
and cheap surgery and whilst
complications can happen everywhere
flying straight after a procedure
increases risks and these package deal
providers are not covered under uk law
this is why berger turns down almost 90
percent of these cases because action
costs more than surgery itself and many
don't have a legal leg to stand on
most of the time these people are being
asked assign these big waivers that are
totally more than a regular waiver and
mostly in turkish and then they simply
give away all their rights like michelle
heath after losing 10 stoning weight she
wanted ridge of the loose skin
paying for a package deal in turkey she
went for a leg and back lift and
returned with open wounds and infection
bruising swelling
skin grafting
leaking
she says the nhs saved her life my legs
were necrotic they needed debridement
um
and then obviously re-stitched up on
whatever and then a week later they
back had opened so i needed major skin
grafts so
the hospital obviously there was
four-week stay in the ulster hospital
and two surgeries it's just so
uncomfortable i used to treat in five
days a week and i'm back to the gym but
i'm not doing what i want to do and i
don't know if i'll ever be able to um
because i can't stretch
michelle's story is one of thousands
echoed on facebook groups like this and
as the number of brits travelling to
turkey increases so does the number of
those returning with major complications
an association of plastic surgeons says
it's the nhs that pays the price for
cheap surgery
it costs an estimated 15 000 pounds per
patient to fix complications
it's calling for mandatory insurance
this would be an additional cost
also it would protect the nhs in that if
they do choose to go abroad should they
then end up with difficulties or
complications and require nhs treatment
that those costs are covered and also it
doesn't disadvantage those people who
have been on waiting lists for
now many many months
for for their surgery and their
procedures
bob says insurance should be mandatory
to push up costs and make cheap package
deals less appealing
to stop both patients and the nhs having
to pay the price for botch surgeries
shimon freeman powell sky news